[Applause]
a russian tank roaring into action not
on the battlefield but at the
international army games in moscow
a fun day out for the family part and
parcel of russia's heavily militarized
culture
in one exhibition hall weapons captured
on the battlefields of ukraine tagged to
show which western nations the kit
supposedly came from mock up ukrainian
troops with far-right tattoos painted on
them in line with russia's incessant and
false narrative that kiev is a nazi
regime
russia's defence minister at a security
conference in uzbekistan admitted to a
slowdown in the fighting because he said
russia was seeking to avoid civilian
casualties and pointed the finger at the
west for geopolitical turmoil
the united states and the collective
west are putting unprecedented pressure
on independent states in an effort to
maintain global domination for this
purpose flagrant blackmail is being used
threats color revolutions and coups a
clear disinformation scheme is being
distributed the six-month milestone
barely mentioned in russia hardly
surprising given the situation on the
battlefield
troops from so-called friendly countries
playing at war while russia's army
suffers huge casualties in ukraine
not that the public here will really be
aware of that because of the degree of
secrecy around casualties or indeed
anything to do with what's happening in
ukraine
we were forbidden from asking what
people here thought about russia's
special military operation the line here
that everything is normal it's all going
according to plan
but this is the other side of that story
the reality of what goes on in russia if
you do speak out evgeny roisman ex-mayor
of the city of yekaterinburg finally
detained on criminal charges for
discrediting the armed forces
he's been fined before now he faces jail
for three short words opposition to
everything these past six months have
been
words you can't even say in russia
donna magnay sky news moscow